new in theaters this weekend the secret
life of pets to dark phoenix and late
night what will you see this is your
weekend ticket we're going on a trip
really we're going in the car I'm in a
car
the secret life of pets 2 opens in
theaters this weekend
in this follow up to the first movie we
follow the many stories of our favorite
pets as Gidget learns to be a cat
snowball shoots up is captain snowball
max learns to conquer his fears and
plenty more fun pet shenanigans my owner
might have given you a bit of catnip
are you finished TSL op2 as the kids
aren't calling it stars the cast of the
first film as well as new cast members
Tiffany Haddish
Patton Oswalt he got the jump on me and
Harrison Ford as rooster the farm dog
who I'm hoping make some kind of
Chewbacca type growl at some point it's
a medical device doctor yeah you're
cured this movie is for you if you're
looking for a fun family movie the seed
this weekend you enjoyed the first
secret life of pets or if you can't keep
a secret like producer Scott dresses up
like a tabby cat on the weekends if he's
offended by it then it's your problem
[Music]
but it feels good thank you threatening
that's right
Dark Phoenix also comes out this weekend
in this follow-up to x-men apocalypse
the still untrained Jean Grey is struck
with a cosmic force amplifying her
abilities and creating instability and
not only her powers but her personality
the x-men now face their most difficult
challenge of taking down their most
powerful teammate while also trying to
save her are you scared little girl he
answers to a man in a chair are you the
most powerful creature on the planet the
Dark Phoenix saga is one of the most
popular storylines and comics and while
it was someone touched on an x-men The
Last Stand this movie promises to really
step it up this movie is for you if
you're a fan of the x-men movie
franchise you look forward to seeing
more sophie turner as Jean Grey or if
you forgot what happens when a toad is
struck by lightning you know what
happens to a toad when it's struck by
lightning
same thing that happens to everything
else oh that's right
who you I'm Molly I'm a new writer don't
sit down okay could you sit down please
let's just use that trash can it's kind
of comfortable better than share
and lastly late night hits theaters this
weekend in this movie written by and
starring Mindy Kaling a diva talk show
host played by Emma Thompson hires a
female writer to her failing late-night
talk show I know what everyone thinks of
me but just because I was lucky enough
to get this job doesn't mean I'm stupid
enough to listen with this new
perspective from her previously only
male writing staff her show has given
new life she now understands the
importance of diversity and she learns
more about being true to herself I will
not be marginalized because no one here
looks like me she's not trying to
silence your strong female woman of
color spirit hashtag me too blah blah
blah he's a new writer with no
experience write something this movie is
for you if you're looking for a comedy
movie with a message you love the
writing of Mindy Kaling or if you had a
late night last night and you can't find
her ha
that is your weekend ticket what will
you see and check back next week to
learn about the secret life of aliens I
wrote that in I'm like yeah
[Music]